what are the Palestinians in the
diaspora
feeling I think deeply
frustrated a great sense of anger
sadness every single Palestinian right
now knows someone that's been killed
every single Palestinian is a part of a
story of displacement or destruction
every single Palestinian has a relative
that's either missing a limb or a loved
one every single Palestinian in the
world is traumatized by
this and in some ways being
outside of Palestine being away from it
all hurts even more because you see your
people being killed and starved and
brutalized and slaughtered and you can't
do anything about it and the people
around you are justifying that Slaughter
if you turn on a TV or if you open a
mainstream news site these sites are
justifying your Slaughter and people are
being killed over there because they
look like me because they're Palestinian
like I'm Palestinian and so we're
watching this in diaspora uh with Agony
we can't go we can't we can't heal our
loved ones we can't Comfort the people
that are there I recently spoke to a
doctor who's lost 75 relatives 75
relatives in God
and he's a medical
doctor and all he wants to do is get in
there and just use his medical expertise
to help his people and he
can't and so we're watching it from afar
but our hearts are there they are in the
buildings that are being destroyed
they're in the hospitals that are being
bombed they are there and they are with
the
people you're somebody who's always
rushed into the midst of a crisis so
what does it feel like on a personal
level to not be able to do that here to
go to Gaza to
help yeah
it's it's really hard I mean when any
group of people are
killed
uh my instinct and I think a lot of
people is to go there to help whether
it's a natural disaster or especially
after an incident of Terror um wherever
it is right it's Rush there and do the
best that you can to help people get
through it um so it's
been extremely hard uh to watch this
from afar and feel like I can't do
anything about it and so that's why
instead I think that uh most of us are
driven to continue to be the voice of
the voiceless you know I always say that
if they've made them faceless they can't
make us
voiceless they have reduced our
casualties in Palestine
to a number the number is
hundreds a day over 30,000 people we're
averaging 10,000 people a month the fact
that they've been turned into faceless
numbers with no stories with no Humanity
makes it that much more important for us
to tell their stories here and to remind
the world that you've lost your Humanity
if you can watch this unfold and not
even have the decency to call for a
ceasefire I mean that's the that's where
we've reached that's how low it is right
now calling for a
ceasefire has now become radical uh so
we have to remind the world that if
you're okay with the Demolition of an
entire town or a city or whatever it is
that you want to call Gaza because it
wasn't always the Gaza Strip but if
you're okay with this and you're okay
with this casualty count every single
day it's not just them who are being
killed bu it's your hearts that are
dying and I think that when I look back
to Dr Martin Luther King Jr and I
mentioned this he wrote about Vietnam he
said that if America was to succumb to
uh its spiritual death the autopsy would
read Vietnam I would say that it would
read Gaza
now